gleich zu beginn aber waren wir über
politik sprechen und sind sehr gespannt
auf das gespräch mit diesem mann mit
einem der von einem wirklich exzellenten
beamten an der spitze einer besonders
sensiblen stelle dieses staates zu einer
politischen reizfigur wurde kann man
glaube ich so sagen seit einem jahr ist
ja nicht mehr präsident des
verfassungsschutzes wir erinnern uns es
war dieses video das eine heftige
debatte darüber auslöste ob es in
chemnitz hetzjagd auf ausländer gegeben
habe oder nicht der sprecher der
kanzlerin hat dieses wort benutzt er
dagegen widersprach und andere auch was
dann passierte hätte die große koalition
fast zerrissen
es war der beginn des endes von andrea
nahles und das war sein ende als chef
des verfassungsschutzes doch die
ursachen für dieses zerwürfnis liegen wo
eigentlich das ist die große frage
herzlich willkommen hans georg maas und
freue mich sehr dass sie heute haben das
wird spannend zu hören
spannend sein zu hören wie dieser mann
das sieht einer der besten die
investigativ reporter dieses landes der
gerade für die kollegen im ersten eine
sehr sehenswerte dokumentation über die
geschäfte arabische clans gemacht hat
beute land ein spezialist für heikle
themen könnte man sagen der es aber
immer schafft deutlich zu sagen was ist
ohne dabei plump oder gar ideologisch zu
sein und deshalb reden nicht nur clan
mitglieder mit ihnen sondern auch
rechtsradikale und erstmal muss man
hinhören wenn er sagt ich würde hans
georg maßen kfd gesinnung unterstellen
aber er und horst seehofer haben den
lügen presse rufen zum teil vorschub
geleistet wie meint er das fragen wir
olaf sundermeyer herzlich willkommen bei
uns hinter sich und konnte sehen dass
sie das
also herr maßen ein ja sind sie nicht
mehr präsident des
bundesverfassungsschutzes was vermissen
sie am meisten
sein britischer kollege der
ausgeschieden war sagte informationen
transportation informationen die man
jeden tag um mass hatte und die einfach
auch wichtig sind um ein weltbild sich
zu bilden also unabhängig von der
dienstlichen tätigkeit man bekommt
informationen aus allen möglichen
quellen und das andere natürlich hinten
rechts im wagen zu sitzen und sich keine
gedanken über den verkehr zu machen aber
ich muss sagen ich fahre gerne auto und
es ist auch gut wieder normal leben
angekommen
aber es ist meine ehrliche antwort also
sie vermissen sozusagen informationen
und ein auto das ist das was sie am
meisten vermissen
also den service habe ich zunächst
vermisst aber in welchen momenten sind
sie froh ist nicht mehr machen zu müssen
der oberste geheimdienstchef dieses
landes zu sein ich sagte ihnen ehrlich
von 49 denen ich tätigkeit übernommen
hatte und es war mir eigentlich klar
gewesen was macht man nicht bis 67
nicht deshalb weil es so risikobehaftet
ist weil es einfach so physisch und
psychisch belastend und sie müssen sie
am zweiten weihnachtsfeiertag aus dem
bett gerufen zu werden möglicher
terroranschlag mann ist bei einer
familienfeier permanent ist man in
alarmbereitschaft 24 stunden sieben tage
die woche
es hat mir freude gemacht aber ich
merkte auch auf die dauer waren meine
akkus leer und es brauchte ziemlich lang
hat ist sie dann wieder aufgetankt
werden also insoweit wartet heute besser
als früher
es ist anders ich bin ich muss auch
sagen ich bin froh dass das dass dieser
lebensabschnitt abgeflossen ist ich
hätte ihn ohnehin irgendwann mal beenden
müssten es war mir klar gewesen wie ich
sagte bis 67 macht man das nicht ich
werde entweder in einer anderen funktion
gegangen oder aus einem anderen grund in
ein zwei buchstaben gegangen und jetzt
bin ich in insoweit etwas ich sage mal
befreiter weil die würde des amtes ist
auch eine bürde und diese bürger die weg
wiegt schon sehr schwer
gibt es punkte an denen sie sagen würden
sie sagen darf ich fehler gemacht man
hat man macht ich würde nicht sagen
fehler sein ich hätte etwas manches
anders gemacht
manches besser gemacht ich muss auch
sagen im nachhinein ist man immer
schlauer
weil wenn man einen vorgang anpackt
weist man im zweifel nicht wieder zu
ende geht nachher wenn du zu ende
gegangen ist dann kann man natürlich
sagen hätte ich das so da anders gemacht
dann wäre auch der vorgang anders
gelaufen da gab es ja eine ganze reihe
von vorgängen wo ich gesagt habe mir
fehlte zum eine information hätte ich
die information gehabt hätte ich das
anders angefragt oder ich habe es aber
gewertet aber nochmal sie haben aus
ihrer perspektive keinen fehler gemacht
jetzt mein sie chemnitz überhaupt also
kenntnis habe ich dabei auch im kopf
beziehungsweise den umgang mit kenn ich
sage ich sage es mal so man hat macht
jeden tag hunderte fehler sei es dass
man sich verschreibt oder ein komma
nicht selbst bei orthografie ist für
mich auch kein fehler das ist einfach
nur ja ich noch als ihr deutschlehrer
würde wahrscheinlich was anderes oder
hätte was anderes gesagt aber hat er war
es geht um vitale fehler um
schwerwiegende fehler um fehler die
wirklich auswirkungen haben ja so sehe
ich derzeit nicht
sie müssten auch unterscheiden herr lanz
bei einem job wie bei demnach zwischen
dienstchef da geht es nicht um fehler es
geht um visiten nahezu jeder vorwand den
ich da in meinem einem pilotenkoffer hat
er war ein risiko vorgang und risiko
vorgang heißt es kann so oder so
ausgehen ohne dass mein fehler macht wie
bei einem arzt der einer operation
durchführt auch wenn er alles richtig
macht kann es sein dass der patient tot
bleibt weiß man nicht man steckt nicht
drin
und bei einem vorgang wo zum beispiel
eine menschliche quelle eingesetzt
werden kann es sein dass die menschliche
quelle einfach aus dem ruder läuft wenn
man macht nicht das was einrichtung
sollte sind das hat für sie das bewerten
wir reden da gleich noch mal intensiver
darüber bevor wir noch mal eine kleine
zusammenfassung davon sehen wir schauen
sie zurück auf diesen september damals
in chemnitz
also ich war was die september anging
ich muss sagen ich war über die republik
schockiert weil präsident des
verfassungsschutz ist ein bedeutender
behördenleiter aber er ist nicht der
wichtigste mann der republik um den sich
alles drehen muss und über den permanent
berichtet werden muss selbst wenn der
präsident des verfassungsschutzes ein
fehler macht und wer macht keine fehler
er macht was gutes muss man nicht
permanent über ihn berichten so die
republik aus meiner wahrnehmung im
september 2009 10 stand kopf und wegen
vier sätzen die ich gegeben hatte ich
wollte eigentlich fünf sätze geben ein
pressesprecher hatte einen
rausgestrichen so sage ich nicht und
damals habe ich mir gesagt also wenn
vier sätze schon ausreichen um eine
große koalition zu sprengen dann halte
ich mich jetzt zurück einen weiteren
satz mehr kein kommentar ich habe
ohnehin nicht die deutungshoheit über
meine sätze war dieses bild interview
war das ein fehler
nein es war es war insoweit keinen
fehler
ich hab's sage mal nicht nur vorsätzlich
gemacht ich habe es absichtlich gemacht
ich habe die sätze seiner zeit auch dem
minister vorgelegt
sie haben dass horst seehofer vorgelegt
ich habe es ihm damals per sms
zugeschickt und antwort einverstanden
ich habe nicht gesagt dass es in die
bild -zeitung gehe ich hab gesagt
minister okay das auch an
unterschiedlich moment für sie ist es
unterschiedlich wollte es in die medien
geben und ok in dem raum weil ich an ihm
weil ich an dem abend solch einem run
mit reichelt von der bildzeitung
zusammen da habe ich ihm gegeben ich
hätte sonst noch einer anderen zeitung
geben weiß weiß der chefredakteur von
bild julian reichelt der auf sie
zugekommen ist oder sind sie auf ihn
zugegangen
ich bin auf ihn zugegangen es bot sich
eigentlich an weil ich an dem abend traf
das ich machen sie können jeden
jederzeit anrufen
ja aber es bot sich an dem abend dann
sind sie befreundet nein warum haben sie
es ihm gegeben
wie gesagt es bot sich an dem abend an
wir fahren
wenn man so wenn jemand von der taz da
gesessen hätten hättens dem von der taz
angebote staub gemacht
sie nehme ich jetzt auch im rahmen eines
interviews gemacht wissen ich habe
niemanden mehr stoppt wenn man wenn man
schon ganz kurz sein aber wenn man alle
zeit der welt ganz ausgereizt ist das
problem das leider nicht aber ich als
rentner gar kein rentner sie sich ja
heute aktiver denn je sie sind im
unruhestand
wenn man wenn man sich überlegt so eine
botschaft zu setzen sie haben eben daher
gesagt ich habe irritiert davon dass die
republik kopf steht wegen vier sätzen
dass man tagelang über nichts anderes
mehr diskutieren ist eine große
koalition hat sich am seidenen faden
hängt ich meine der andere teil der
wahrheit ist ja sie waren derjenige der
diese öffentlichkeit erst gesucht hat
und sie sind ja der präsident oder der
der chef sozusagen des geheimdienstes
das heißt operieren im geheimen
man vermutet denn überall aber ganz
sicher nicht in der bild zeitung so
geheimen sind die auch nicht auch weil
ja sie haben ja sie haben mir gesagt ich
hätte jede zeitung nehmen können und sie
wissen ja ich habe damals sehr sehr
viele interviews gegeben und da habe ich
auch nicht unterschieden
ich habe wirklich nicht unterschieden
weil ich der meinung war die medien
müssen gleich behandelt werden
ob es nun die taz ist oder ob das ard
zdf und zu wollen sie das gewollt hätten
hätten sie es an die dpa gegeben das ist
die große nachrichtenagenturen dann geht
es dann alle gleichmäßig raus das haben
sie ja nicht gemacht
nein ich habe ihn ja versucht ich merke
sie glauben mir nicht meine natur wissen
wir natürlich nicht nein weil das und
weil das einfach nein weil ja das
abendessen mit julian reichelt wir haben
uns getroffen
danach habe ich die pressen presse
verfolgt von dem tag herr kretschmer hat
sich geäußert ministerpräsident auch in
ähnliche richtung wie sie über
lebensjahr in die jade hat sich noch
direkter gottheit ich habe gesagt nach
mir vorliegenden erkenntnisse habe ich
zweifel
ich habe zweifel ja nach den mir
vorliegenden kenntnisse minister
seehofer hatte sich dazu gehört und an
dem tag hat ja auch eine schlechte
berichterstattung bekommen er hatte er
den satz geprägt die migration ist die
mutter aller probleme und da habe ich
ihm nach dem arm hat er recht jetzt
machen sie ein neues fass auf die frage
nur nein
das waren einfach hinein
herr seehofer nein das ist nicht die
mutter aller probleme ist etwas anderes
da können wir auch gerne darüber reden
wollen ihr bitte ja die mutter und aller
probleme aus meiner sicht ist das die
politik in deutschland mehr wunschdenken
verfolgt als realität sind das ist aus
meiner sicht die mutter aller probleme
der migrationspolitik
das sehe ich in der klimapolitik wo die
realität nicht als realität wahrgenommen
wird wie ich und viele andere sie sehen
sondern man wünscht dass die realität
anders unter sich also ein großes
problem ist dass ernsthaften problem ist
es nicht gut wenn wenn politik
irgendwann auch sich traut angesichts
ernsthafte herausforderungen die leute
nicht den klimawandel beispielsweise
gehören ja zu den reinen das ist wir
haben da ein thema als mensch hat eine
echte herausforderung
also ist es nicht gut wenn politik an
einer stelle wir beklagen dass er so
häufig dass politik eben keine vision
entwickelt keine idee davon entwickelt
wo die reise hingeht das meine ich gar
nicht schauen sie mal nehmen wir ihr
thema klima ich bin ein befürworter
gewissen atomenergie weil ich der
auffassung war wenn man atomenergie hat
dann muss man das von a bis z durch
denken er braucht nach endlager aber so
weit ist man nie gekommen
also hat man nicht gemacht finde ich gut
dass man aus der atomenergie deswegen
aussteigt aber atomenergie ausstieg
ausstieg aus fossilen brennstoffen und
nur setzen auf eine technologie die wir
noch gar nicht haben die auch niemand
ausprobiert hat bei einem industrieland
einem hoch industrie land im herzen
europas wo ich sagen das ist nicht nur
risikobehaftet ich glaube wir gehen hier
nicht mehr von den realitäten aus die
wir haben und das macht mir sorge
genauso bei der micra des wasserbettes
1,07 millionen menschen haben wir
aufgenommen seit 2012 als nur als
asylsuchender dazu kommt noch
familiennachzug dazu kommen noch die
ganzen leute die illegal gekommen sind
und einfach sagen wir sind in der lage
die alle zu integrieren und die sagten
da verkennt man die realitäten die
realitäten sind anders und wer die
realität nicht als realität wahrnimmt
ist nicht in der lage probleme zu lösen
die frage ist trotzdem war sie haben in
dem zusammenhang fällt mir gerade ein
etwas gesagt von dem ich gerne wissen
würde wie das gemeint ist sie sagen ich
bin nicht vor 30 jahren in die cdu
eingetreten
damit dann irgendwann 18 millionen
araber in dieses land kommen ja das ist
das für einsatz
was ist das für eine frage was wir uns
die frage ist warum von jemandem wie
ihnen von jemandem ihrer intelligenz von
jemandem ihres kalibers die ein so
undifferenzierter satz nur gut das war
ein okay ich versuche mal den
hintergrund darzustellen als war ein
satz den ich verwendet habe in einer
weder glauben habe ich so verbindet ist
in der zeit vor der wm haben sich die
von der werte und das war in der nähe
von heidelberg gewesen den satz habe ich
ein anderer weise eben vorher auch schon
mehrfach verwendet ist allerdings nie
aufgegriffen worden
der hintergrund war gewesen wie sie
wissen dass ich in den siebziger jahren
junge union und danach in die cdu
eingetreten bin und da hatte die cdu
eine ganz andere ausländerpolitik gehabt
ich habe ja selbst an aus der politik
nach 1990 mitgewirkt habe das asyl
grundgesetz mit geändert artikel 16a sie
haben sogar promoviert ich habe auch
darüber promoviert ich gehörte auch wenn
die wahl der sockel ihrer doktorarbeit
die völker die die feststellung des
asylbewerbers im völkerrecht
das ist ein thema das sie lange
begleitet und geleitet nicht lange ich
habe unter otto schily das
einwanderungsgesetz gemacht so nun muss
ich zur kenntnis nehmen dass 207
millionen asylsuchende nach deutschland
gekommen sind obwohl um uns heroben
sichere drittstaaten sind ja alle
staaten sind sicher drittstaaten und 16
absatz 2 satz 1 grundgesetz sagt
asylrecht genießt nicht wer aus einem
sicheren drittstaat kommt so da muss ich
sagen ich bin damals nicht in cdu
eingetreten dass gleichwohl 2,07
millionen asylsuchender oder überspitzt
formuliert 1,8 millionen araber nach
deutschland kommen aber nochmal warum so
zugespitzt sie sagen die 1,8 millionen
araber wissen sie wie das klingt das
klingt wie so ein awd-sprecher wobei ich
kenne einige leute aus der fdp die
würden das so gar nicht sagen
ich sage ihnen mal wenn man öffentlich
wahrgenommen werden will
da muss man ab und an auch überspitzten
deshalb in diesem jahr auch wahrgenommen
aber noch nicht um jeden preis
nein ist es das wert was ist es gehört
ist es das wert dass man so zuspitzt um
dann wahrgenommen zu werden um das
schauen sie mal ich habe in diesem jahr
34 veranstaltungen wollte ich zuerst gar
nicht über die leute sind einfach mich
zugekommen massenkommunikation ski kommt
ins kino auch zwei wand ich war letzte
woche in altmittweida gewiss nicht wahr
in buxtehude gewesen usw untersagen wenn
die leute endlich sagt mal das was ich
auch immer sagen will aber ich traue
mich nicht mehr dazu sagen
er spricht das aus und spricht klartext
er spricht es so dass die leute das auch
verstehen
und deswegen habe ich das auch gesagt
deswegen habe ich auch zum beispiel vom
shuttle service gesprochen weil das ist
das was die leute im grunde erwarten
dass man das ausspricht dass man darüber
auch einfach diskutiert herr lanz und
nicht die proben lassen 60 werden zeigte
sich dass manche zieht ihren weil sie es
gerade ansprechen lassen sie sich nicht
einreden dass es sich um seenotrettung
handelt diese migranten sind keine
schiffbrüchigen und keine flüchtlinge
sie haben als einwanderungswillige
ausländer die schleuser boote bestiegen
um von einem shuttle-service nach europa
gebracht werden
flüchtlingsboot als shuttle service das
sagen sie weil andere leute das hören
wollen nein das sage ich das sage ich
weil ich mir wirklich sorgen macht um
diese situation dass verbringe ich habe
nein nein nein nein es kommt auf das
frame henkern es kommt auf die worte an
sind das nun schiffbrüchige sind es
flüchtlinge sind es leute die in seenot
gerettet werden oder handelt es sich
hier um schleusung um arme opfer von
schleusern ich habe einige jahre habe
ich mich mit organisierter kriminalität
beschäftigte lanz und ich weiß dass das
meiste geld im bereich organisierte
kriminalität nicht mit rauschgift
gemacht wird sondern mit menschen weiß
dass sie sehr jungen menschen die werden
in der subsahara aus den dörfern
herausgelockt die wir mit lastwagen über
die sahara bis zum küstenraum gefahren
weist auf alte boote gepackt und werden
dann auf gummiboote gesetz richtig es
ist keine seenot um die es geht soll das
wird vorsätzlich werden die leute da
ausgesetzt vorsätzlich werden sie
ausgesetzt
dem ziel dass angeles oder als militärs
wieder abholt und das ist ein
shuttle-service wenn sie von frame
gesprächen shuttleservice nach europa
wissen sie was das problem dabei ist
dass ich damit habe ist es geht nicht
darum problem dazu beschreiben ich bin
sehr bei hinunter neben ihnen sitzt
einer der bekannt dafür ist genau das zu
tun dinge klar zu benennen aber ohne
dabei ressentiments zu schüren
und wenn man solche wörter benutzt dann
dann klingt das so despektierlich dann
ist das eine sprache von der ich denke
gerade jemand von ihrem gewicht und auch
jemand der diesen job gemacht hat ja und
auch von ihrer intelligenz sollte sowas
einfach nicht sagte punkt okay
[Applaus]
genießen sie den beifall ich bin ganz
anderer meinung ich bin ganz anderer
meinung ich werfe den medien vor
das sind bewusstes fremming machen dass
sie bewusst von flüchtlingen sprechen
weil flüchtling hört sich nach besonders
schutzbedürftig sind keine flüchtlinge
sie genauso wie alle ihrer kollegen
wissen flüchtlinge sind personen die
einen status erhalten haben
vorher sind es allenfalls asylsuchende
sind migranten oder sind sie hörten dass
sie versuchen damit eine bestimmte
weltsicht zu zu generieren das gleiche
wenn man von zeno tretet besonders
hilfsbedürftig und ich habe den affront
begangen ihnen gegenüber und dem vielen
kollegen und politikern dass ich das
nicht akzeptiere dieses frank ich
akzeptiere es nicht dass sie von
flüchtlingen reden dass sie von seenot
reden sondern ich erwarte dass man
darüber redet um was es geht
es handelt sich um schleusung und diese
tausenden bedauernswerten menschen
werden in seenot gebracht vorsätzlich in
serie gebracht und wir helfen mit wir
helfen mit teilweise geschäft nicht
kaputt machen er maßen sie erwischen da
gerade den falschen tatsächlich wir
haben hier öfter über diesen wettlauf
des elends den man auch so nennen kann
gesprochen das ist überhaupt kein
bringen sich von flüchtlingen von seenot
dann reden sie von leuten ich rede von
wörtern wie shuttleservice ich rede von
wörtern bis vier frames kirchenjahr und
und sie benutzen dieses wort
shuttleservice verpflichtet wissen sie
ganz in das sind ja keine flüchtlinge
herr lanz das sind migranten
einigen wir uns doch einfach darauf dass
man versuchen mal die richtigen worte zu
verwenden flüchtling ist jemand der
anerkannt ist als asylberechtigter oder
als bürgerkriegsflüchtling okay ich
schaue mir das noch mal eben an
shuttleservice für flüchtlingsboote
shuttleservice für schlichtungsprozess
sie haben dieses wort benutzt sie tun
die ganze zeit so als hätte ich erst
dieses wort in die runde geworfen
sie benutzen die ganze zeit in diesem
tweet das wort flüchtlinge die werfen
des meeres vor das kann man so nicht
machen
mir geht's um das wort shuttle service
und es geht darum welches welches bild
von menschen und auch von unserer
eigenen humanität wir eigentlich
vermitteln wollen wenn wir solche wörter
benutzen sie wissen doch auch ganz genau
wenn sie solche wörter benutzen dass sie
an einer ganz bestimmten stelle ganz
sicher applaus kriegen
und wir reden so viel darüber und sie
als ehemaliger chef des
verfassungsschutzes wissen dass doch
noch viel besser wir reden von gräben
die sich auftun wir reden von einer
spaltung der gesellschaft von einer
verrohung der sprache von der art und
weise wie wir mittlerweile miteinander
kommunizieren
von der art und weise wie in amerika
wahlkampf geführt wird von der art und
weise wie auch hier geredet wird und ich
finde einfach dass solches training wie
sie es nennen an dem punkt nicht
funktioniert mailands ich glaube in
einer ganz drei punkte sind für einer
meinung wenn ich mir keinen
möglicherweise ja dass wir haben eine
zutiefst gespaltene gesellschaft eine
wirklich zutiefst gespaltene
gesellschaft mein eindruck es wird
eigentlich von tag zu tag schlimmer und
ich glaube das problem liegt einfach
auch an ihrem frank und wenn die
flüchtlingsboote verwendet habe da war
es ein begriff ihrem nicht wer war
zuerst da sie oder ich also ich bin auf
den mag ich bin eher die hoffnung sie
herr maßen
ich hoffe ich das gar nicht mal auf dem
politischen markt erst relativ spät
gekommen als ich gemerkt habe als ich
gemerkt habe dass das die gräben schon
gesetzt sind und als ich gemerkt habe
dass die menschen hier zu erwarten aber
wirklich das argument verreckt jetzt
wirklich auf dem weg hierher doch nicht
ernsthaft sagen wir haben hier gräben in
der gesellschaft und ich sorge dafür
dass sie noch ein bisschen tiefer werden
das bringt uns doch nicht weiter nein
wir müssen wir müssen wir müssen die
probleme benahmen sich probleme gras
wenn sie solche wörter benutzt nein ich
verstehe nicht warum sie nicht hingehen
und sagen was auch wir haben hier ein
thema wir sollten differenzieren sie
sind ein exzellenter jurist und ich
finde es völlig richtig ja aber sie
können also gar nicht beurteilen
nein aber ich rede mit leuten ich rede
mir sorgen und ich habe mal den quellen
und ich gebe einfach davon sind sieg ein
exzellenter jurist
ich habe mich noch nie selbst vertreten
aber sicher sind sie dass sonst kommt
man auch nicht in solche positionen otto
schily hat sich sehr geschätzt andere
leute sehr geschätzt und sie sie waren
ein exzellenter beamter so lange ich
sage nochmal was ich will ich will dass
wir über die probleme wäre ja das tun ja
also frage ist wie wir würden heute gar
nicht über shuttleservice reden wenn ich
diesen satz nicht verwendet habe mir
geht es da richtig ja aber wenn er geht
es einfach darum dass wir über das
grundlegende problem reden
es handelt sich hier nicht um
flüchtlings mündung sie können es auch
nennen aber das angebot muss man so eine
billige person leider hinlegen und das
sind leider in dort dann nutzen wir
beide sind leider in deutschland schon
an dem punkt wo man selbst solche sagen
wir billigen tricks verwenden muss weil
die leute nicht mehr miteinander reden
und weil die leute nicht mehr bereit
sind die probleme beim namen aber eher
maßen sie können nicht von fremden
sprechen und dann so eine billige nummer
machen sie beleidigen ihre eigenen daten
bewegt
wenn wir jetzt nicht auf die tour sowas
thema wunderbar erst einmal nicht gar
nicht wechseln
wir sind jetzt da mittendrin hallo wir
sind jetzt sowohl regie erschöpft sie
machen mich fertig olaf sundermeyer ist
bei uns das thema ist auch zu ernst um
jetzt scherze darüber zu machen
der sagt zum thema fremming leute wie
hans georg maßen und auch horst seehofer
haben an einem bestimmten punkt unter
manchen stellen und ausgesprochen auch
differenziert nicht an jeder stelle aber
genau diesen lügen presse schreien
diesem gefühl man darf nicht mehr alles
sagen es werden dinge verheimlicht und
so weiter vorschub geleistet wie meinen
sie das
also unabhängig davon dass herr maßen
das jetzt täglich macht mit seinen
twitter- botschaften über die er sich so
ein bisschen radikalisiert nachdem er
ein paar monaten eben nicht mehr nicht
mehr dieses wichtige dieses wichtige amt
innehat und da eine menge zuspruch und
applaus aus der aus einer blase bekommt
da gibt es eine wechselwirkung ist für
mich etwas entscheidendes gewesen ich
kann mich noch sehr gut erinnern als ich
diesen text in der bild zeitung gelesen
habe das war nach einer woche nachdem
ich drei mal und zwar hinter dem steuer
und nicht hinten rechts im auto in einer
woche nach von berlin nach chemnitz
gefahren bin und mir an drei tagen in
dieser stadt dort treiben angeschaut
habe mir dort angeguckt habe was dort ab
offen ist selbst massiv angefeindet
angegriffen wurde das ist so als
reporter zumal wenn man dort gewesen in
chemnitz zimmern öffentlich über diese
über diese zusammenhänge berichte und
auch richtig was in dieser sendung ja
hier nach nach dieser machtdemonstration
des rechtsradikalen flügels der afg und
wenn ich in diesem kontext dort wurden
menschen verfolgt auf den straßen dort
herrschte im prinzip eine massive
gewaltbereitschaft dort wurde vom ersten
tag an hat die gesamte gewaltbereite
rechtsextremistische hooliganszene
deutschlandweit mobilisiert ich habe
selbst sprachnachrichten gehört sofort
an dem tag nachdem dieser schreckliche
dieser dieser dieser dieser mord kann
man nicht sagen dieser totschlag
deutschland gefunden hat auf dem
stadtfest in chemnitz haben hooligans
mobilisiert zu sagen wir fahren nach
chemnitz [ __ ] klatschen ich gebe das
jetzt wörtlich wieder das ist ein zitat
ist eine wahnsinns verlauf des schlosses
geschlossene geschlossene gruppen zu
denen man zugang bekommen kann zudem
herr maßen noch viel besser zugang
bekommen konnte als ich seinerzeit ich
weiß dass der verfassungsschutz
zumindest in sachsen das quasi in
echtzeit auch so mitbekommen hat und in
diesem kontext macht im prinzip der
höchste verfassungsschützer und ich
beschäftige mich seit vielen jahren mit
der arbeit nicht nur da das der
bundesverfassungsschutz sondern auch der
landesverfassungsschutz ämter solche
zitate raushaut der bild zeitung im
prinzip so also so ein interview gibt
was völlig von der diskussion abgelenkt
da geht es gar nicht darum zu sagen ist
es jetzt eine hetzjagd wie viele meter
brauchen wir um etwas als hetzjagd zu
definieren oder nicht das ist reine
wortklauberei wir werden dann war es
natürlich semantisch so das eigentliche
problem ist die roher gewalt eine
stimmung die
schon etwas pogrom artiges hatte die in
diese richtung ging eine sehr
aufgewühlte stimmung sehr sehr
gewalttätig und dann findet so eine
wortklauberei stadt von jemandem den ich
einfach nur unterstellen kann der eine
gewisse politische agenda wir haben es
gerade gehört das war seine idee dieses
interview der bild zeitung zu geben da
würde ich meinen da soll einfach der
verfassungsschutz in dem augenblick die
seine arbeit machen und nicht meinung
über über über diese große bild zeitung
darüber die über dieses boulebahn medium
lenken und das habe ich genauso
empfunden und wir haben es ja auch
gespiegelt gekriegt in chemnitz selbst
ich habe es jeden tag selbst gespiegelt
gekriegt was herr maßen verzapft hat zu
sagen seht her ihr berichtet nun lügen
nicht nur seit chemnitz seit jahren
immer wenn über päda berichtet hat wenn
er über über rechte aufmärsche im osten
bericht und dann ist es alles
manipuliert und von der antifa antifa
gesteuert gewesen und das ist der
vorwurf den ich nicht nur herr maßen
mache sondern auch den
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer der
in dieser woche auch gesagt hat wenn ich
bürger wäre und kein bundesminister
hätte ich sogar selbst an
demonstrationen chemnitz teilgenommen es
ging eher maßen verdiene auch um den
einen satz letzter teil möglicherweise
die öffentlichkeit von dem mord in
chemnitz abzulenken
das war's denn juristisch für sie
juristisch entscheidet dass das gericht
und sie beschreiben warum haben sie
diesen begriff benutzt mord macht
normalerweise klappt man immer an wenn
das höchsten in frage kommen
tatbestandes und nicht wegen
fahrlässiger tötung oder
körperverletzung mit todesfolge
aber lassen da habe ich zwar nicht dafür
war die rolle von herrn halte also es
ging um den sonntag 26 august 2008 10 3
uhr noch etwas war der deutsche
staatsangehörige daniel schwerst
verletzt worden danach ist er gestorben
zwei weitere verletzt worden
dann gab es zwei demonstration am
nachmittag eine von der afg die
friedlich verlaufen war und eine von
rechtsextremisten die weniger friedlich
verlief aber es kam im wesentlichen so
nach polizeiberichten anderen bericht
nicht
hatte zu rempeleien zum pfefferspray
einsatz und ähnliches keine hetzjagd und
das ist keine semantische wortklauberei
und das bestreite ich das ist ein großer
unterschied ob pfefferspray eingesetzt
wird von polizeibeamten ob hitler gruß
gezeigt werden usw nicht rede vom
sonntag 26 ich rede nicht vom 27.09
folgen haben das ist entscheidend ist
deswegen entscheiden verdammt tag drauf
die tagesschau und andere unter berufung
und belegt dieses antifa videos gesagt
haben es gab hetzjagd denn nicht nur
eine in chemnitz so alle die von der
sache etwas verstanden selbst die
lokalpresse neue presse chemnitz
berichtete es gab keine hetzjagd
es gab keine hetzjagd freie presse freie
presse aber es stimmt was sie sagen ja
es gab keine hetzjagd es wurde damals so
aber tagesschau berichtete dass und
andere persönlichkeiten berichteten auf
sagten es gab es ja so an dem tag als
die medien über hetzjagd berichtete ging
die post in chemnitz richtig aber ich
versuche mal es somit ganz plakativ zu
sagen gegen die post ab es wurde richtig
gewalttätig aber auch keine hetze
million waren ebenfalls in diesen tagen
kein hetzjagd bekannt geworden sind
schwere straftaten begangen und ich
glaube auf ein jüdisches restaurant sind
angriff gemacht worden
es sind viele maler der ja also ich
glaube 200 ermittlungsverfahren
strafverfahren sind eingeleitet worden
aber zwei nachfolgenden tagen gewesen so
was mich interessiert hat 100
verfassungsschutz präsent bin ich nicht
mehr für rechtsextremismus zuständig
gewesen sondern auch für desinformation
wieso haben die medien über heads jagten
berichtet dies am sonntag gar nicht
gegeben hat wir konnten doch gar nicht
wissen dass es vielleicht am mittwoch
oder ein paar tage später hetzjagd und
geberit wieso hat die tagesschau das
gemacht wieso haben die ausgerechnet ein
antifa video als beleg genommen was für
zusammenhänge gibt es zwischen der
tagesschau und antifa und das sind aus
meiner sicht berechtigte fragen die sich
ein präsident des verfassungsschutzes
stellen muss wenn nämlich die ganze welt
in den folgetagen überhitzen
berichtete ich hab so rische im boden in
japan gesehen
die new york times hatten alle über
diese hetze ab und berichtet so und da
muss ich sagen da muss ich mir wirklich
die frage machen was ist die motivation
gewesen von den deutschen medien an dem
montag von hetzjagd ist oder wenn sie es
niemals als wenn sie sagen es gab keinen
beleg sozusagen aus ihrer sicht für und
das will ich jetzt überhaupt nicht in
zweifel
warum spekulieren sie auf der anderen
seite dann direkt weiter machen
sozusagen das nächste fass auf und sagen
ich kann eigentlich nur vermuten da
wurden gezielte falschinformationen
gestreut
seidler weise ganz kurz die
öffentlichkeit von einem mord abzulenken
herr lanz das ist dass das ist eine
große das ist eine große unterstellung
nein das ist keine frage
und die frage die müssen sie nicht an
mich stellen sondern zum beispiel an
herrn kniffe von der tagesschau
warum hat der gfk nein also wenn man
wenn man behauptet es gab jagten und
benutzt dieses video da und es gab keine
hetzjagd
dann müssen sich die journalisten die
frage gefallen lassen wieso haben die
das berichtet aber es ist gut mit leuten
ich muss da jetzt rein ja vermaßen sie
machen hier und jetzt und heute weiter
das was sie tun ist hochgradig
gefährlich und ich bin x-fach auf
veranstaltung nicht nur in chemnitz
überall in sachsen in brandenburg an
allen allen orten wo ist ein paar tage
dauert bis sie anschließend berichte auf
ihren schreibtisch auf ihren
schreibtisch hatten bin ich selbst dabei
und sehen was 2004 was sagt 2014 in
diesem in diesem land los ist das erste
mal habe ich hier in der sendung
besetzen nach den ausschreitungen von
hooligans gegen salafisten in köln
da gab es anschließend an
landesinnenminister der sagt
rechtsextremisten waren da höchstens 15
prozent und hat diesen 5000 randalierern
die versucht haben die kölner innenstadt
auseinanderzunehmen und seit dieser zeit
da heizt sich das klima deutschlandweit
und auch wie immer wieder entzündet
durch solche entscheidenden punkte wie
in chemnitz wie in cottbus wie in cannes
sowie an anderen seiten auf und sie
behaupten immer noch steif und fest hier
und heute darüber zu reden ob das jetzt
das richtige wort wedding damit den
achten müssen
dann setzen sie sich doch einfach mit
der redaktion der tagesschau auseinander
darüber ob man diesen begriff hetzjagd
oder nicht das ist doch im verhältnis zu
dem was in deutschland abläuft und was
sie dadurch grundsätzlich anzweifeln und
er ist in dem langsam losgehen nicht
wenn ich dort ich bin dort und ich nicht
weil ich hinten leute die schreiben dann
dieners war die leute schreien ja auch
schreit man herrlich schneiden aber
lassen sie an als lügen presse sondern
mich und wissen sie warum weil den
zuschauern weil sie noch mal angeschaut
noch sie machen eine veranlassung die
halle auch solche dinge steht die machen
eine veranstaltung in bad godesberg mit
der werde wette union halten einen
vortrag ein lokaljournalist berichtet
darüber in einer art und weise die ihnen
nicht gefällt und sie rufen über twitter
dazu auf das abo vom bonner general
anzeiger zu kündigen das sorgt dafür
dass die menschen mögen presse rufen
nach der strafe doch also dass das ist
wirklich eine unverschämtheit
ich bin fit ich habe mir gerade noch
erleben das problem ist dass die leute
das problem ja das problem ist ja okay
dass das problem ist dass die leute mehr
und mehr den medien nicht mehr glauben
glauben denn nicht und sie reiten darauf
herum indem sie dieses system und diese
wortklauberei bis zum aufhören sie doch
kaufen das problem sind sie das sind die
medien ich bin das problem dass hopp
möchte ich jetzt mal hören was wo ist
meine berichterstattung das problem
nicht ihre berichten die medien
aber das sind es sind die medien ist
immer dass ich mit ihnen verlangt zwar
ziemlich erzieherin die zange nehmen
ich werde mich jetzt ihnen soja
versuchen ja hier versuchen ist jetzt
ein bisschen lesen sie ist ein ganz
alter geschmacks
oktober wieder sagten lasst uns das
bitte auch das problem das problem das
problem 2015 kleine mädchen
willkommenskultur
das problem war an silvester gewesen
tage später versetzt wurde darüber
berichtet
die menschen haben zweifel gehabt dass
die tagesschau die öffentlich
rechtlichen medien hier noch
wahrheitsgemäß berichten oder ob das
hier manipulation ist so die der glaube
dass die medien die menschen
wahrheitsgemäß unterrichten hat
abgenommen und das nicht an mir ja das
liegt nicht an mir leute also sie
verstärken den trend natürlich
selbstverständlich sie verstärken den
trend wenn sie blödsinn berichten also
olaf sundermeyer ist tatsächlich einer
ich hab das auch ich sage jetzt das
medium an die medien ich war aber das
ist ja aber das ist ja der der
rhetorischen kniff dabei die araber die
medien die migranten die die
öffentlichkeiten sie nicht dass ich das
gleiche spiel wie sie spielen die
kleinen mädchen mit den großen
kulleraugen das sind ihre asylsuchenden
sie überspitzen eine wir jetzt reden wir
mal was ganz anderes als wir reden jetzt
über die situation 2015 wo die
öffentlich rechtlichen medien eine
szenerie dargestellt haben die nicht der
realität entsprach herr maßen wissen sie
was der punkt ist 2015 wenn also den
ball kann man natürlich auch elegant
zurückspielen ich aber ich will mich
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mit ihnen
streiten weil ich finde das thema ist
auch viel zu ernst um auf so einer
primitiven holzschnittartigen ebene
darüber zu regieren wenn sie noch da
stimme ich ihnen zu ja wenn sie in amt
und würden sind 3015 war das ja auch sie
hätten doch in 2015 sagen können pass
auf ich gebe einen seriösen medium ein
großes interview
lasst uns bitte darüber reden dass wir
hier möglicherweise eine verzerrte
darstellung der dinge haben das können
wir doch tun
darüber kommen wir doch sprechen wir
reden doch jetzt ja auch offen darüber
genau in diesen öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk den sie so furchtbar finden da
sitzen sie jetzt gerade
warum stellen wir uns den machen wir
doch sie haben sich doch 218 auch an
jemanden gewand in chemnitz und sie
haben sich an jemanden gewandt der auch
gelegentlich eine agenda zu haben
scheint sag ich jetzt mal juristisch in
aller gebotenen vorsicht
warum haben sie das 215 nicht gemacht
215 beispiel anderen situationen und war
ich möchte der chef des
verfassungsschutzes war natürlich chef
des verfassungsschutzes ich habe
natürlich meine berichte an die gegeben
um die es auch gegen und die sind
natürlich auch eine entsprechenden
gremien beraten worden
das
ich bin damals damals in teilen auch in
die öffentlichkeit gegangen
dazu geäußert ich kann mich erinnern ich
habe damals in einem großen interview
mitgewirkt das war beim deutschlandfunk
deutsche deutschlandfunk gewesen ich
habe einiges dazu gesagt aber ich spiele
ihnen bald wieder zurück sie als
öffentlich nicht sie als person sie als
öffentlich rechtliche medien haben 2015
über etwas berichtet was nicht der
realität entsprach sie meinen jetzt dass
es überwiegend junge männer waren die zu
uns gekommen sind ja darauf heben sie ab
oder wenn sie an diese mäßige mit einem
kollegen ja ok ja also unbenommen ist es
so und da gibt es auch viele debatten
darüber und dann war ist ja herr lanz
das haus ist das konsequenzen haben
das muss doch nicht nur ganz kurz wer
das ist dass das ist an dem punkt da gab
es ja auch einen wirklichen lerneffekt
und das land das wir haben nicht gelernt
glauben sie mir sie haben nicht gelernt
sie machen ja immer noch weiter es hat
ja auch keine konsequenzen gab kein
intendant ist zurück getreten worden
keinen chef vom dienst ist
zurückgetreten und ich sagen okay wir
haben damals einen fehler gemacht und
jetzt ist alles gut nein es ist nicht
gut es geht ja weiter chemnitz was
ähnlich gewesen weil maßen wissen sie
was ich mich frage ob man anders machen
was man hat dann hat diese sozusagen
diese diese entfremdung den begonnen
dann hatten sie das gefühl ich sitze da
nicht mal der richtigen stelle und
dieses land ist auch nicht mehr das land
das sich vertreten möchte er so gut an
dass allein das ist das dass es nicht zu
treffen das ist glaube ich eine analyse
die nicht zutreffend ist also was ich
gesehen habe über all die jahre ist dass
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk mehr
und mehr versucht meinung zu machen
statt tatsachen zu bringen und ich muss
sagen wenn es ihnen ja auch werden dass
die bild -zeitung macht oder wenn es
andere private medien machen können sie
es machen das sind tendenzbetriebe der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk
unterliegt einem ganz anderen regime
und wenn ich jetzt erschien die
entschuldigung als jurist als jurist als
jurist wenn ich nur aus weißem rechts
regime das ist der rundfunkstaatsvertrag
ja also entschuldigung als jurist werden
stehen aus sicht der politiker verstehen
sie mich aufgepasst
als ich finde politisch denken ich bin
kein politiker sie sind in der cdu sind
der wehrte union sie auftreten im
wahlkampf auf sie betätigen sich
politisch schreibenden kollegen
ich bin kein politiker ich bin wird
welches spiel spielen sie dann herr maas
wenn sie wenn sie das so machen dann
sage ich ihnen dann dann kneifen sie an
einer entscheidenden stelle
warum warum das ist ja mein punkt und
das ist auch die kritik die ich wirklich
an sie richten muss an nach kalisalzen
auch sie halten das ja auch aus die
kritik ist warum arbeiten sie dir nicht
konstruktiv an dieser stelle mit warum
so platt warum sagen sie nicht passt auf
wir haben dann problem und lasst es uns
versuchen gemeinsam zu lösen
ich habe eine idee wie wir es
möglicherweise erinnern können was sie
haben ja recht das natürlich bedanken
dass wir ja hallo wir sind noch nicht im
luftleeren raum das wissen sie doch auch
sie wissen dass wir in afrika ein
bevölkerungswachstum haben das enorm ist
nigeria wird zwar ist das jetzt sogar
sagen das ist unglaublich das ist
unglaublich das bevölkerungswachstum zur
seehofer hatte vor einigen wochen gesagt
das war's 2015 passiert ist das kann
sich jederzeit wieder ja und da sehe ich
ganz genauso und ich habe diese wir sind
nicht drauf vorbereitet und ich sage dir
noch etwas sollte ich denn haben sich
gerade die degenhart habe ihren
redefluss zu unterbrechen
ich sag dir noch etwas meine sorge ist
dass immer mehr menschen sich von diesem
staat abwenden
und sie haben vorhin mir gefragt was ist
in mir vorgegangen 2050 mehr vorgegeben
dass ich festgestellt habe die leute die
die angriffe asylunterkünfte machen
waren überwiegend jedenfalls die
festgestellten tatverdächtigen waren
überwiegend keine rechtsextremisten
waren keine nazis gewesen war noch nicht
mal leute gewesen doch 70 meilen kern
waren war die entsprechende ist für mich
der entscheidende entscheidende ansatz
das waren leute gewesen das waren leute
gewesen
die gehörten eigentlich zur bürgerlichen
mitte und die haben sich radikalisiert
haben quatsch quatsch also das waren das
waren leute gewesen sie gehörten zur
bürgerlichen mitte und die haben sich
radikalisiert die haben dann ein
übergriff auf eine asylunterkunft
gemacht und da habe ich festgestellt der
staat nimmt hier eine entwicklung und
die gesellschaft nimmt eine entwicklung
wo wir es nicht zu tun haben mit einer
nicht nur mit einer spaltung sondern
auch mit menschen die bisher in
tragenden säule dargestellt eine säule
dargestellt
die ich abwenden von dem stadt mainz hat
sie diese zurückzugewinnen
skinheads mit springerstiefeln die sie
kein rufen sind nicht teilt damit er
dieser gesellschaft personal werde der
landtag brauchen wir gar nicht um die
geht es nicht es geht im grunde um die
kleinen angestellten um normale menschen
die angriffe asylunterkünfte machen um
die geht es mir es geht mir nicht um
nazis wir haben über dieses thema hier
schon häufiger und auch dabei auch sehr
in ihrem sinne sehr differenziert
gesprochen wie bewerten sie das wie
sehen sie das
grundsätzlich glaube ich das ist ein
drastischer fehler war der
sicherheitsbehörden in den vergangenen
jahren
wer ist ein rechtsextremisten da muss
man in der npd sein oder in
irgendwelchen organisierten
kameradschaften um dann überhaupt mal
auf den schirm zu beraten oder
irgendwelchen organisierten gruppen
dieses netzwerk über das wir
mittlerweile alle um zum glück reden
auch übrigens ehemaliger dienstherr
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer der
sagt wir haben dieses netzwerk nicht
richtig erkannt wir müssen irgendwie da
die sache ausleuchten aus diesem
netzwerk kamen viele derjenigen die 2015
flüchtlingsunterkünfte angezündet haben
und wir haben da seinerzeit eine große
fernseh dokumentation darüber gemacht
für die ard wir haben uns mehrere dieser
dieser dieser angriff auf
flüchtlingsunterkünfte ganz genau
angeschaut auch mit den leuten die
dahinter stecken die dann die täter
gewesen sind usw
insofern greift das wesentlich zu kurz
woher maßen absolut recht hat und da bin
ich kommt mit bei ihm ist dass wir eine
radikalisierung erleben von sehr vielen
menschen die im prinzip nicht mehr
mitmachen wollen bei diesem
demokratischen in diesem in diesem
demokratischen diskurs indem wir zum
glück alle in dieser sendung immer
besitzen sondern die scheren aus weil
sie zusätzlich sich selbst
radikalisieren oder radikalisieren
lassen unter anderem auf eine art und
weise die ich das muss ich jetzt mal
verlobt zu sagen und ich respektiere
grundsätzlich die arbeit von hammerson
aus der aus der vergangenheit wenn ich
sehe wie da jemand der nicht mehr in amt
und würden ist jetzt einigen monaten
entfiel auf twitter im prinzip eine
eigene öffentlichkeit
bearbeitet aufheizt aufheizt ja auch das
gegen die medien nicht nur gegen einen
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk aber in
besonderer art und weise das beispiel
mit dem shuttleservice haben wir jetzt
gerade selbst gehört dann finde ich das
unverantwortlich zumal von jemanden der
diese zusammenhänge und der die
situation die wir gerade haben in
deutschland sehr gut erkennt da muss man
vom gaspedal runtergehen stadt noch
mutwillig darauf zu treten als ich für
falsch
das verkennt das verkennt aus meiner
sicht dass die menschen ja nicht einfach
so wo sich radikalisieren zu hause hat
er einen grund dieser grund liegt zum
einen in einer politik die diese
menschen nicht verstehen oder die sie
nicht haben wollen liegt aber auch in
teilen aus meiner sicht daran dass sich
in medien nicht mehr wiederfinden dass
sie mit ihren positionen in den medien
kein gehör mehr finde
und wenn ich habe jetzt nicht wirklich
ich da sitzt sie bei desinformation das
stimmt einfach so
wir sind jeden tag unterwegs und bilden
das ab was die leute denken was sieht
bin am tag der wahl am 19
eine große idee dokumentation in sachsen
unterwegs gewesen mit afd wlan mit
leuten die sagen ich kann die cdu nicht
mehr wählen
ich suche etwas anderes und diese leute
finden stundenlang stadt im öffentlich
rechtlichen fernseh programm und das zu
recht
ich habe neulich eine
fernsehdokumentation gemacht über
kriminelle clans nicht die erste und
nicht die erste
wir haben hier gesessen wir haben hier
zusammen gesessen und haben ein thema
aufgegriffen
herr sonne mal hat ein buch gemacht über
rumänische banden die hier aktiv sind
wir haben da sehr klar und deutlich und
ohne ressentiments zu schüren darüber
gesprochen hier saß jens genießer den
sie kennen mehr sicherheit der
vorsitzende des deutschen richterbundes
deren buch geschrieben hat das ende der
gerechtigkeit in dem er beschreibt dass
unser justizsystem in echte
schwierigkeiten kommt und dass sich
leute da haben sie recht vom staat
abwenden weil sie sagen wenn ich fünf
km/h zu schnell fahre werde ich
erbarmungslose sanktioniert hüfte und
wenn ich aber in diesem mittleren
bereich wo es also nicht um mord und
totschlag geht der selbstverständlich
geahndet wird
in diesem mittleren bereich unterwegs
bin also sachbeschädigung und so weiter
dann findet das nicht mehr statt und
wird sozusagen
einfach nicht mehr bearbeitet weil die
behörden überlastet sind alles themen
über die wir hier sehr lange und
ausführlich und immer wieder gesprochen
haben ich selber aber mehrfach können
sich in der mediathek angucken
dokumentation gemacht mit ganz normalen
menschen in diesem land überall
unterwegs gewesen öffentlich rechtliches
programm in den usa in england in
deutschland unterwegs gewesen ich habe
ein ganz gutes gefühl dafür was da
draußen eigentlich so los ist und wenn
ich eines gelernt habe auf dieses diesen
reisen ist es zu differenzieren man muss
differenzieren
ich finde einfach wir sind auch im
moment in einer sehr ernsthaften
situation müssen wir wenn man in der
welt sind alle schon in situationen
darstellen situation genau wenn man sich
in der welt umschaut die welt rückt
zusammen es gibt diesen großen prozess
der globalisierung
es gibt viele viele millionen menschen
die chinesen haben den letzten
jahrzehnten 600 millionen menschen aus
armut geholt für die wahl globalisierung
ein großer erfolg
aber was ich sehe wenn ich durch amerika
reise auch durch england reise auch
durch deutschland reise und so wie jetzt
gerade in italien gewesen wo eltern dann
toilettenpapier für die schulen ihrer
kinder mitbringen müssen sondern sie
auch mal vorstellen
wir produzieren im westen und davon bin
ich wirklich überzeugt durch die
globalisierung sehr viele verlierer
und wir müssen eine antwort auf diese
fragen für die antworten sind schwierig
und die antworten sind nicht
holzschnittartig und sind nicht
shuttleservice nach europa und und und
umsatz aber die einfach sind auch nicht
einfach wegzuschauen und so klein sind
recht nein aber das macht nichts sie die
öffentlich-rechtlichen von flüchtlingen
reden statt zu sagen was sind migranten
wir müssen uns dem migrationsproblem
stellen
ja aber das tun wir doch nein das tun
sie doch gerade nicht dass ich meine
wenn wir da zusammenkommen könnten
landes wären wir heute schon einen
schritt weiter
wenn sie bekommen ihre ford zusammen
wenn sie mir einräumen würden die medien
haben einen fehler gemacht sie haben
über flüchtlinge gesprochen migranten
sind gekommen okay dann über kleine
mädchen und ihre mutter gesprochen und
viele viele junge männer sind gekommen
wenn wenn sie sagen würden da haben wir
einen fehler gemacht und das muss
wirklich konsequenzen haben dann würde
ich auch sagen dann brauchen wir auch
nicht über shuttleservice zu reden
jedenfalls über das wort dann würde ein
anderes wort mehr ausdenken
ok also danke sehr für eine sehr
lebhafte diskussion